welcome back to the why everyone I'm
back honeymoon yeah now I can make
videos again leave your entries in the
sir really close how do I make them I
forget how does this work let's see what
kind of memes you guys have been posting
while I'm away
I'm surprised if anyone has even posted
anything you know if I disappear it's
interesting to see what will happen to
this sub ready will it take a new life
on its own
perhaps no it's minecraft fan art a very
epic I took this month maybe I've been
away longer than seven days though I
just simply cannot imagine he's to you
game hard enough gamers you'll get a
wife at some point to peers playing
horror games again new subs that came
from Minecraft videos true veterans only
true PewDiePie fan veterans only people
that were actually 9 when they started
watching me will understand this me
pyramid in Egypt
pyramid in Australia oh my god is that
true
you know I I was on the honeymoon in
Bali oh she's fairly close to Australia
and I met a couple Australians but they
weren't upside down it really made no
sense
can we appreciate for a moment how
creative PewDiePie fights the bosses how
big brain he fights the bosses come on
back to the future verse then you're
about fixed did I say that is this one
of those memes where I'm like I'm too
lazy to look up so I'll upload anyway at
wedding [ __ ] lasagna comes on Felix mom
be like I think I've seen this but it's
it's 100 I think I reacted to this but
it's 100 percent accurate I just want to
sorry
so sorry to interrupt video it's time
for me out of all things to talk about
Lords mobile that's right everyone
despite me roasting little Lords mobile
or having the worst commercials I'm
sorry for having the greatest
commercials of all time okay
look a fly angel despite how these ads
look like believe it or not they told me
that they actually perform really good
so well played Lords mobile they were
surprisingly cool about it not only did
they joke about it but also the girl
that recorded the original video
responded to it as well I thought that
was really cool I just really want to
emphasize it's really cool that Lords
mobile actually reached out to do this
promo with me they're awesome they
support me and they said that they
really like my content Lords mobile nine
year olds confirmed but they also wanted
to support by giving back to the nine
year olds so they came with an amazing
offer of fifty thousand in cash to
people that download and play a large
mobile you guys know me I'm all about
strategy every single time I think about
20 steps ahead like that I name a
character with the glasses that flare up
that's for me in Lords mobile and Lords
more ballet is considered by a lot of
people do I sound natural like the other
people doing commercial like the
ultimate strategy game brah did I just
get anther VIP - I'm good at this okay
so first we're gonna Scout oh he has
mixed unit I think this calls for the
arrow formation so I've been playing
this game and what's nice about it is
that unlike other games like fortnight
which takes up a ton of time you can
play this whenever you want wherever you
want and still have an amazing gaming
experience especially when you were this
good I got a call on whatsapp ignore I'm
gaming one of the things I like most
about is that you can be a no can I say
that sorry what I meant was you can be
mischievous in this game which is
personally the main reason I enjoy
playing games online you can capture
execute and charge the ransom for other
players online and if that's not a good
reason to play this game I don't know
why I think that really takes me back to
all
games as well cuz that's what gaming is
all about so what I need you guys to do
is download the game link it in the
description use that link because then
you enter the $50,000 prize pool and by
clicking on the link you will also get a
$350 Lords mobile gift pack you are
welcome
Thank You lords more by for sponsoring
this video very cool
download now my mom doing the airplane
move to the spoon with food here comes
the airplane
two-year-old mean this subreddit truly
is a subreddit for intellectuals my god
so this is what you guys have been up to
huh amazing damn I always loved nature
expand art they're always so dope oh
they have it actually looks cool the
thakura but they're friends now right
the old netflix having a house made of
diamond blocks using jukeboxes as
furnace fuel wait you can do that i
don't know but i'm too lazy to check i
will i will check it out in minecraft
billy
Eilish I was born at young age 14 year
old girl that's deep
my mom is a huge Billie Elish fan so
she'll be appreciative of this meme as
well thank you very much I just want to
say I get it and I've already seen it
and I've already laughed at it
that's how minecraft veteran I am Peter
pies intros has changed so much 2011 to
2017 how's it going bros my name is
Petey Pitts 2015-2019 good morning
gamers Felix and Marcia wishing you all
the best
Wow wait how how this is work how
explain science how this work that's
pretty cool boat dragon yes I've seen
this so it is true you can capture it in
a boat very well it must be done here he
goes
the thing is there's bedrock there he
clearly removed bedrock in creative mode
how am I supposed to do that right
because it flies down to the pillar of
bedrock I can't delete that we're gonna
capture everyone in boats I love your
accent
say it again ship ship the real reason I
got Marcia ship ship
wow thanks when you rename your horse PD
PI with the PD PI packs what that's so
cool wait why would you name your horse
PD play why would you do that hey stop
oh that's so cute
spends Mother's spends mother-effing
damn that's awesome yeah already did a
funny
oh god no the worst one is the one with
Jack you know I've seen a lot of these
photo shops there one where it's both me
kissing myself or my DCI herself or they
stop my friend who did nothing me with
69 iron ingots sick 3232 this is
literally when me and Jack plays
minecraft every single time if we
revived minecraft sooner it would have
been an end game instead of fortnight oh
my dog yeah I watched I finally watched
all the Marvel films I had nothing to do
on the plane so now I understand all the
memes I saw the fortnight bit that was
very cringe so you guys like those films
that's cool alright the bat the battle
at the end was was cool okay fine
I'm finish off with Dennis back from
honeymoon I've got my mom like this
photo
thank you mom very cool James Charles
Belle Delphine is shaking that's right
everyone this is just a promo for my new
backwater yes it costs $29
that's a great price march Lincoln BIOS
represent Comstock PD PI limited time
bath water you know at the honeymoon the
hotel prepared so much in their Villa
like flowers and smells and chocolate
and champagne and I'm like
this is a freak chamber this is exactly
what I do to my village
I think minecrafters built this hotel
and forgot to delete that block that's
embarrassing the new most liked comment
on YouTube SEF ever meant I'm the fall
guy really that's awesome
is that the most like one bra my mom
would like that when you realize felix
has laugh that means without uploading
my why stops okay alright it is like
that
my girlfriend tied in our minecraft
server instead of spawning in our house
she's spun inside my friends have that
hurts that stinks
that's a big-ass big-ass Epps in the
chat boys damn my girlfriend's cheating
on me how did you find out well we were
playing minecraft teacher passing notes
will get you nowhere in life
mailmen girls in high school oh my god
if there's so much negativity in the
world people need to be more positive
also girls in high school
wow you're really poor wow that's so
awesome super simulator has so much mean
potential guys come on
well admitting Bank died putting back
his name tag after reddit realized
skipping all memes about banked on Lawai
going on honeymoon to Leatherface banked
it what what do you think name tags can
fall off okay move on my disappointment
is immeasurable and my day is ruined
wait what happened here Oh what if you
put bedrock on the other side what have
you put obsidian I mean on the other
side this is beyond science again
seriously that's right
oh man what you never had you know it's
yumm right well cut you a deal it's
available for two dollars and that's a
great
Marketing done right they'll be putting
this line on in classes in schools how
can we increase our sales with a hundred
percent a thousand percent Tetris in
Minecraft whoa what is this
what okay that's that big it is actually
done in Minecraft because if it is
that's really cool ooh damn ah that's
good
I I could probably build that in
Minecraft no problem no problem at all
gamers just want to remind you the
hundred million called merch is finally
out check it out they're selling like
hotcakes represent calm such peopie i
would wear mine I lost them okay I guess
I'll have to order one if you have a
youtube account PewDiePie is technically
your coworker alright yeah sure she got
in the boat oh that's how you know you
sealed the deal you get your wife in the
boat but it's gamer time wait I'm in
your English book what is pewds doing in
my English book I have lived in Britain
for some years I have lived in Sweden
for more than 20 years also hope you
guys learned epic English I was trapped
underwater for three days
Sven first time 12 hour minecraft stream
I'm still trying to figure out when
we're gonna do it
I will obviously do it very soon as soon
as I can
it's just that I just got back wedding
has been so busy and I already have so
much stuff to catch up on that I kind of
put aside but it will happen and it will
be the most life-changing experience of
all time goes with Photoshop boys with
Photoshop look good this is a new meme
ten years ago these green monsters were
added to the game happy 10th fret delete
dates they were a mistake just like you
oh yeah nvidia has the new is that out
yet when is it out it's going to look so
epic look at the graphic imagine if
someone in the future makes a PewDiePie
movie from the University drop out to
selling hot dogs meeting wide sales
starting making YouTube videos and to
the big explosion with a bro army then
the transition to the dark hey alright
we can call it those yes sure and vacuum
2016-2017 that I endure larvae teasers
battle and then finally nice ending
getting married playing Minecraft and
being the first person to reach 100
million you're speaking as if my whole
YouTube is over I understand that we
have clearly peaked okay I don't know
what to do
yep no one Felix Skyblock thumbnails big
boy took me a second I wonder why dogs
are always happy 100 million wedding you
know usually when people are fortunate
online that's when your audience turns
against them they're like oh you know
what screw this guy but it seems like so
many people are actually happy for me
and that it's really heartwarming which
app is so useful that you cannot believe
it's free
reply to birth simulator the same boy is
the same person commented ultra-thick
boy oh boy
Thank You ultra-thick boy 69 very cool
that's good me why does mine say I have
a pee pee on her bag oh that actually
made me laugh well done
hey good photo right good photographer
right Lammas when I attack the wandering
traveler momís when someone attacks me
I don't get it I didn't get a minecraft
mean oh god oh no my power is going away
my mom talking to visitors me telling
her pity pie hit hundred million subs I
drew every pewdiepie minecraft thumbnail
damn it took hundred hours brah no I
can't take hundred hours can it well it
looks awesome thank you
I mean I'm not an artist and I can't
draw but surely hundred hours hey this
place he was familiar what wearing merch
epically I should have worn my merch on
the day come on 2014 cutie pie at least
better gameplay than minecraft trivia 19
Felix isn't uploading videos on his solo
minecraft world because he's on
honeymoon and he he doesn't pre-record
that series yeah because they take me so
long to add it there's no way I could
have done that so many people in the
comments like it's okay go and break
Felix haha coincidence I think not
damn even the color bra when you see a
wolf but you have no bones my god this
is the most relatable meme of all time
I'm sorry I can't keep you I still love
you though
the first peepee poo-poo to join the
army must ha ha ha good meme good meme
I'll save it
nobody lasagna in microwaves good meme
gird me what puberty did to my friends
what people did to me god damn it
I finally had time to watch Avengers and
Jojo on my honeymoon on the plane so
finally I thought I would understand the
memes but what it what is this I don't
understand yep the Council of Watership
has decided you will vote for Julian and
co-current alright well it looks like
it's written in stone isn't it
congratulations Julian in court Kane
minecraft 86,000 fortnight 80,000 The
Return of the King
step aside for tonight we need to start
a petition to edit out fortnight out of
Avengers endgame and retro actively add
my minecraft letsplay
series yes okay damn that's sick that's
so cool
this kid has 100 million subscribers
stop digging up my old photos yeah I had
spikes yeah they were cool 9 year olds
when PewDiePie reads a meme on the why
with Swedish accent oh so epic baby pie
bird
berry pie Birds oh my god me running
away from air if you still want to be
bang same thing yeah it disappeared they
disappear everyone knows this delete
this meme girls with Photoshop I can't
wait to make myself look pretty boys
with Photoshop chip shop this is
brilliant
but I like this oh yeah oh my god that's
so cute yes yes that's awesome
spend after taking one heart of damage
steak this one's for you
I love house spider-man memes are coming
back so good my friend here is a
longtime fan that constantly buys merch
your friend here will get enough of very
cool stop making the mission so epic
epic me god I haven't looked at memes in
so long I'm just like I can't stop the
first guy to drop school sell hotdogs
and being married at 100 million
subscribers must have been like ah what
do I do now feel like I'm past the end
credits I'm like I don't know what to do
now yep
Wilson shopping carts be like oh yeah
alright gamers hope you guys enjoyed
this episode of the why it's good to be
back I'm excited to make more videos
feels really good to say that don't be
the person that misses out on 100 mil
merch link in the description see you
guys tomorrow bye gamers well you
haven't tried to pursue me later at City
after 50 million out routes fetch
don't just doubt it's still relevant
just down